there are a million and one different
ways to praise a movie attendees of
Hollywood premieres and festival
screenings will often stand right up in
the theater and cheer as the credits
roll here are a few movies that earn
themselves a standing ovation when they
hit the big screen nearly 30 years ago
Spike Lee took the film world by storm
when his uncompromising racial drama do
the right thing made its premiere at the
Cannes Film Festival
since then the in-your-face director
proved himself as one of cinema's most
gifted if often divisive filmmakers by
releasing a steady stream of
artistically ambitious and politically
themed movies in 2018 Lee took Han by
storm with the timely racially charged
black Klansmen the true story of an
african-american police officer who
infiltrated the Ku Klux Klan in the
1970s there's never been a black cop in
this city we think you might be the man
to open things up around here
simply put black Klansmen is a film that
refuses to be ignored
according to Variety the usually stuffy
can crowd seemed more than happy to give
the film its due awarding it with a
six-minute long standing ovation as well
as the festival's Grand Jury Prize the
other flick to get the haughty crowd at
the 2018 can Film Festival to its feet
was of all things a remake of a horror
movie
it helps of course that this remake was
directed by Luca Guadagnino the man
behind 2017 s oscar-winning heartbreaker
call me by your name the stylish lead
demented and utterly brilliant remake of
Suspiria wisely doesn't stray too far
from the original bewitching narrative
[Applause]
but Guadagnino manages to twist the
formula in shocking new directions and
he takes his sweet time in letting this
unholy tale unfold the result is an epic
150 minutes of pure horror hysterics and
according to Deadline had brought the
canned crowd to their feet for nearly
eight full minutes there is more than a
little reason to worry when Danny
McBride and David Gordon Green set out
to reboot the Halloween franchise as we
learned more about their film
particularly that it would ignore all
those ill-fated sequels and remakes our
fears began to subside wasn't it her
brother who murdered all those baby
centers yeah it was not her brother
that's the main that people made up but
the odds still seemed stacked against
the new Halloween living up to the
originals legacy not officially in
competition at the 2018 Toronto
International Film Festival Halloween
instead had its premiere at a midnight
screening playing to an eager crowd of
film critics and horror enthusiasts
according to the LA Times that crowd met
the return of the boogeyman and to take
no prisoners turn from Jamie Lee Curtis
with the expected amount of Glee giving
the film a standing ovation and helping
launch it towards a record breaking
box-office run while Kristen Stewart
became famous with starring roles in
big-budget fluff like the Twilight
franchise it's worth noting that she
built her career by starring in indie
flix and continues to shine in the indie
world personal shopper which made its
premiere at the Cannes Film Festival in
early 2016 is an eerily muted study of
loss and grief in the guise of a sexy
paranormal thriller though the film's
initial Festival screening met with a
slightly divisive reaction from critics
the official premiere event was quite a
different scene with Variety reporting
that the audience heaped some serious
love on Stewart in the form of a lengthy
standing ovation after scoring
back-to-back hits with the formidable
one-two punch of Creed and black panther
Brian Kuebler has proven himself a rare
director capable of making big-budget
films at all but demand you stand up and
Cheer neither of those films however was
his first project to inspire a standing
ovation alongside his go-to actor
Michael B Jordan that honor belongs to
2013's based on true events
Fruitvale station parts slice-of-life
drama and part damning examination of
police brutality googlers sobering film
premiered at the 2013 Sundance Film
Festival winning the hearts of festival
audiences and a couple of the festival's
top prizes Fruitvale station's
undeniable virtues were further praised
on the international stage when it made
its way to can and according to color
lines received a rousing standing
ovation